Yine yeni yeniden diyoruz. Yepyeni bir
başlıkla yeniden karşındayım. Güzel
arkadaşım 9. sınıf tayfa yeni marif
modele en uygun şekilde konuları
birlikte temizlemeye devam ediyoruz.
Modül 1'i yani birinci temamızı
bitirdik. Geldik ikinci temamıza. Belki
de sizin yeni marif modeldeki en önemli
konularınızdan birine geçiyoruz. Hatta
belki falan değil ya çok net söylüyorum.
Lise hayatınızın yeni muhalif modeldeki
en önemli konusu nicelikler ve
değişimlerdir. Yani diğer adıyla sizin
daha böyle rahat alışabileceğiniz bir
isimle fonksiyonlar, fonksiyonlar
konusuna giriyoruz. Bu dersle birlikte
artık fonksiyonların temelini atacağız
ve fonksiyonları önümüzdeki 10, 11, 12
sınıflarda da görmeye devam edeceğiz. Bu
yüzden inanılmaz önemli olan bu konuda
eğer burayı, bu temayı doğru bir
şekilde, iyi bir şekilde anlarsan
ilerleyen yıllarda da rahat edersin.
Bunu sana çok net bir şekilde
söyleyeyim. Şimdi modül bir bitirmiştik.
Geldik artık modül 2'ye. Modül 2'miz
çıktı. Kondisyon yayınlarından. Bu sene
yine bu kitaptan ilerlemeye, modül 2'den
ilerlemeye devam edeceğiz. Aşağıya
linkini bırakıyorum. 130'lik bir fiyat
etiketi var. Şu an itibariyle benim
gördüğüm kadarıyla en ucuz ya da sen
nerede bulabilirsen artık. İkinci modülü
de tamamen birlikte baştan sona konu
anlatımıyla, soru çözümüyle,
ispatlarıyla, her şeyiyle beraber
bitireceğiz. Anlaştık mı? Ne yapıyoruz?
O zaman lafı daha fazla uzatmıyorum.
Elimizde kalemler, önümüzde kitaplar,
açtık ilk sayfayı dedik ki hocam gönder,
gönder gelsin. Evet, ikinci temaya
geçtik. Şimdi ikinci temada bizi neler
bekliyor? Önce bir şöyle kısaca bir
görelim konu başlıklarımızı, öğrenme
çıktılarımızı. Öğrenme çıktılarının
ardından da konumuza geçişi yapalım.
Başlığın aslında genel adı nicelikler ve
değişimlerdir. Ama eski müfredatta bu
fonksiyonlar olarak adlandırıldığı için
genel tabiriyle de hep fonksiyonlar
kelimesini kullanacağımız için biz bu
konuyu fonksiyonlar olarak da
adlandırabiliriz. İlk olarak sana f(x) =
x doğrusal referans fonksiyonunu
anlatacağım. Referans almak diye bir şey
vardır ya. Her şeyi ondan referans
alarak türeteceğiz, üreteceğiz. 10.
sınıfta da aslında yine f(x) = x, f(x) =
x² referans fonksiyonları veriliyor ve
onlardan 2. dereceden fonksiyonlar
üretiliyor. Bizim şu anki tek derdimiz
1. dereceden yani kısaca g(x) = a + ya
da - f(x) + - - r + - k şeklindeki
fonksiyonları beraber burada üreteceğiz.
Doğrusal fonksiyondur özünde sadece
bunlar. Buradaki harfler seni
korkutmasın. Bununla ilgili bütün
özellikleri, nitel özellikleri sana
anlatacağım. öğrenme çıktımız bundan
ibaret. He sonrasında neye geçeceğiz?
Mutlak değerli doğrusal fonksiyonlara
geçeceğiz. Orada da onları anlatacağım.
Onların hepsiyle ilgili bilgileri
vereceğim. En sonunda da doğrusal
fonksiyonlarla ifade edilebilen denklem
ve eşitsizliklerle içeren problemleri
birlikte çözüp bu temaya da tıpkı
birinci temada olduğu gibi noktayı
koyacağız. Anlaştık mı? O zaman lafı
daha fazla uzatmayalım. PDF çözüm için
kare kodu okutabilirsin. Video çözümler
için yine kare kodu okutabilirsin.
İçindekiler kısmını gördün. O zaman
hazır mıyız? Elimizde kalemler.
Heyecanlı bir an. Gerçekten matematik
adına 10. sınıf, 11. sınıf, 12. sınıf
bütün lise hayatını etkileyecek
matematik adına en önemli dönüm
noktalarından birincisin. Anlaştık mı? O
zaman başlığımız neydi hocam? Doğrusal
fonksiyonlar demiştik. Doğrusal
fonksiyonlarda ilk olarak doğrusal
fonksiyonun tanımını görelim.
Değişkenleri arasındaki ilişki doğrusal
olan denklemlere doğrusal denklem adı
verilir. Biz bunu aslında 8. sınıfta
şöyle gördük. Evet, 8. sınıfta olan bir
şeydi bu. Doğrusal denklemler başlığı
adı altında 8. sınıfta şu anlatıldı.
Nasıl anlatıldı hocam? A, B, C birer
gerçek sayı olmak üzere elimize böyle
bir denklem verildi. ax + by + c = 0
aslında nedir? Bir doğrusal denklemdir.
Ama 10. sınıfa geldiğinde biz buna bir
tanım kümesi bulacağız. Bir görüntü
kümesi bulacağız. Yani belli bir tanım
ve görüntü kümesi adı altında bunu artık
bir fonksiyon olarak nitelendireceğiz.
Hocam fonksiyonlara geçiş buradan zor
mu? Orada yaptığımız çizimlerin,
grafiklerin aynılarını yapacağız. Tek
fark gösterim şöyle değişecek. A ve B
birer gerçek sayı. A0'dan farklı olmak
üzere f(x) = ax + bçimindeki
fonksiyonlara doğrusal fonksiyon adını
vereceğiz. Hocam çok değişti aslında.
Çok bir şey değişmedi. Burada y diye
gördüğümüz ifade aşağıda kayboldu değil
mi? Aslında kaybolmadı. Bizim gözümüzde
y e= aslında f(x). f(x)'i de bundan
sonra nasıl tanımladık? ax + b. Bu nasıl
bir fonksiyonmuş? Doğrusal fonksiyonmuş.
Bak henüz ağzımdan referans fonksiyonu
tabiri çıkmadı. Çünkü daha onu vermedim.
Önce doğrusal fonksiyonun tanımını
yapıyorum. Doğrusal fonksiyon nereden
geliyor? Doğrusal denklemlerden geliyor.
Oradaki y ediliyor. Y daha doğrusu
karşıya atılıyor falan. Denklem
düzenleniyor. y = fx'tir özünde. O da
eşittir ax + b. Peki hocam buradaki y =
fx biçimindeki fonksiyonda tanımlanan
fonksiyonda x'ler ne anlama geliyor? X
ve Y aslında birer değişken ama burada
bağımlı ve bağımsız değişkenler var. X
değerleri bağımsız değişkendir. Yani
kafasına göre değerler vereceğiz. Tabii
kafasına göre değerler diyorum ama biz
bunu tanım kümesi içerisinden seçeceğiz.
X'e bağlıdır bizim Y değerlerimiz.
Neden? X burada 1 ise Y'nin değeri başka
çıkacak. X burada 2 ise Y'nin değeri
başka çıkacak. Evet, Y değişiyor ama
kime bağlı olarak değişiyor hocam? X'e
bağlı olarak değişiyor. O halde X bizim
için ne oldu? Bağımlı değişken oldu.
Anlaştık mı buraya kadar? Güzel. Şimdi
artık doğrusal referans fonksiyonunun
denklemini, kuralını sana verebilirim
arkadaş. Yine gerçek sayılar kümesi
üzerinde tanımlı. Bu cümle önemlidir.
Çünkü bu cümlenin değişmesi sorularda
sorunun çözümünü de değiştirecek. Gerçek
sayılar kümesi üzerinde tanımlı demek şu
anlama geliyor. Biz bir fonksiyonda
birazdan açıklayacağım sana ama şimdiden
yazmakta fayda var. X'leri tanım
kümesinden seçeceğiz. Bulduğumuz X'ler
de görüntü kümesindeki Y'leri bize
verecek. Eşleştirme mantığıyla bulacağız
aslında. Şurada da y'ler var. X'leri
alıp y'lerle eşleştiriyormuşuz gibi
düşünebilirsin. Nasıl yani hocam? Az
önce bak doğrusal fonksiyonun kuralını
vermiştim. Mesela 2x + 1 olsun. Ben
burada x yerine 1 yazarsam hocam f1
dediğim değer ne gelecek? X yerine 1
yazdın cevap 3 geldi. Aslında f'ler de
neye eşitti? Y'lere. Demek ki y değeri
ne geldi? 3. X yerine 1 yazınca Y'miz ne
geldi? 3. Aslında ben 1 ile 3'ü
eşleştirmiş oldum. Bu şekilde
tanımladım. bana gerçek sayılar kümesi
üzerinde tanımlıdır dediğinde aslında
şunu söylemeye çalışıyor. X'leri diyor
gerçek sayılar kümesinden seç. Reel
sayılar kümesinden seç. Bunun üzerinde
tanımlıdır demek daha başka ekstra cümle
kurmuyorsa demek ki görüntü kümesinin
elemanları da yine reel sayılardan
çıkacaktır anlamına geliyor. Ama şimdi
geldim doğrusal referans fonksiyonuna.
Normalde doğrusal fonksiyon nasıl
yazılıyordu? f(x) = ax + b şeklinde
yazılıyordu. Sadece f(x) = x yazarsam
sana bu doğrusal referans fonksiyonudur.
Bütün doğrusal fonksiyonlar f(x) = x'ten
faydalanılarak üretilir." Bak ne diyor
burada. "Diğer tüm fonksiyonların f(x) =
x referans fonksiyonu yardımıyla
cevirsel gösterimleri, nitelikleri ve
nitel özellikleri belirlenir." Şimdi ilk
defa burada geçen ne var? Nitel
özellikler var. Bir fonksiyonun nitel
özellikleri dediğimizde neler geliyor
aklımıza? Hemen onları görelim. Bunları
da tek başlıklar altında ben sana
işleyeceğim. Hiç kafanda soru işareti
olmasın. Neleri öğreneceğimizin aslında
bir nevi başlıklarını sıralıyorum sana
burada. Bir tanım kümesi. Az önce biraz
bahsetmiştim. Daha detaylı bahsedeceğiz.
Görüntü kümesi. Az önce bahsetmiştim.
İşareti. Bir fonksiyonun işareti vardır.
Pozitif olduğu, negatif olduğu, 0 olduğu
yerler vardır. Artan ya da azalan olduğu
yerler vardır. Bir fonksiyonun maksimum
minimum noktaları olabilir. İlla vardır
diye bir kural yok. Sıfırları vardır.
Evet. bir fonksiyonun 0'ı olabilir. X
eksenini kestiği noktalar diyeceğiz.
Onları da anlatacağım sebebini. Ve bir
fonksiyonun birebirliğinden
bahsettiğimizde aslında o referans
fonksiyonun nitel özelliklerinden
bahsetmiş olacağız ve bunların hepsini
bu ders içinde öğrenmeye devam edeceğiz.
Şimdi öğrendiğimiz kadarıyla acaba biz
soru çözebilir miyiz hocam dediğinde çok
temel haliyle bir tane soruya bakalım.
Birim zamanda eşit işlem kapasitesine
sahip bir bilgisayarın zamana bağlı
bilgi yükleme işlemini gösteren
fonksiyonun değer tablosunun bazı
yerleri boş kalmıştır. X dakikayı
veriyor. f(x) de gab'ları veriyor bana.
Tamam mı? Yani x'leri alacağım. Bir f(x)
değeri elde edeceğim. Elde ettiğim f(x)
değeri nasıl işliyormuş? Aslında kural
zaman geçiyor. Bu zamanda da eşit işlem
kapasitesini gösteriyor bize. Örneğin 0
dakikada kaç gigab işlem yapıyor? 0 GB
geldim. 2 dakikanın sonunda birim
zamanda eşit kapasitede işlem yapıyorsa
demek ki 2ci dakikanın sonunda 2 GB'lık
işlem yapar. Bu arada bu gigab diye
okunuyor ha. Teknoloji kanallarını iyi
takip ederim. Orada doğru okunuşunu
orada söylemişlerdi. Örneğin 4 dakikada
kaç gigab'lık işlem yaparsın hocam? Bire
bir ilerliyorlar. Yani 4E 4. Misal 6'ya
6 8e 8. O halde 10 dakikada kaç
gigab'lık işlem yapıyorum? 10 GB'lık.
Hiç kafanda zorlaştırma. İnanılmaz
kolaydır aslında doğrusal referans
fonksiyonu. Burayı anladıktan sonra
geçiş önemli. Diğerlerini tabloda boş
bırakılan yerleri doldurunuz. Doldurduk.
Fonksiyonun cebirsel gösterimini
yazınız. Bir fonksiyonun doğrusal
fonksiyonun cebirsel gösterimi nedir?
f(x) = ax + b şeklindedir. Bu neydi?
Doğrusal fonksiyonun cebirsel gösterimi.
Ama bana verilen fonksiyonda x'e ne
yazarsam cevap y'de de aynı mı çıkıyor?
ya da f(x)'in cevabı da aynı mı çıkıyor?
Aynı çıkıyor. O zaman bu fonksiyon
aslında nasıl bir fonksiyon? Doğrusal
referans fonksiyonudur. O zaman nasıl
ifade edilebilir hocam? f(x) = x
şeklinde ifade edilmelidir. Niye?
Örneğin ben x yerine 0 yazdığımda f(0)
cevabı ne çıktı? 0. X yerine 1
yazdığımda F1'in cevabı ne çıktı? 1. X
yerine mesela ne yazmış? 6 yazmış. 6
yazdığımda cevap ne çıktı hocam? 6.
Dikkat edersen x değeri neyse elde
ettiğim karşılığındaki cevap da o değeri
oldu. Güzel. Şimdi başlangıçta hafıza
tamamen boş olan 12 GB hafızalı bu
bilgisayarın bilgi yükleme işlemini
temsil eden fonksiyonun grafiğini
çiziniz. Hocam dur ne yapıyorsun? Ne ara
grafiğe geldik falan deme. Aslında
doğrusal fonksiyonların grafiklerini
doğrusal denklem adı altında nerede
görmüştük? Dedim ya 8. sınıfta
görmüştük. Yine benzer şeyi yapacağım. O
zaman ne yapıyorum? Koordinat düzlemini
çiziyorum. Y eksenini çizdim. Geldim x
eksenini çizdim. Benim için önemli olan
şey önce noktaları belirlemek. Mesela
bak 0a 0 f(x)'i neye eşitlemiştik? Y'ye.
Aslında burası bir koordinat düzleminde
nokta belirtir. 0a 0 noktası. Burası
koordinat düzleminde bir nokta belirtir.
2'ye 2, 4e 4 6'ya 6 8'e 8 gibi. 10'a 10
gibi. Doğru mudur? Peki biz 12 GB
hafızalı yani maksimum 12'ye kadar
gitmemi istiyor. O zaman geldim dedim ki
hocam bak 1in karşılığında cevap ne
olacak? 1 noktayı koydum. Geldim. 2'nin
karşılığında cevap ne olacak hocam? 2
noktayı koydum. Nokta nokta nokta
diyelim ki 12'ye kadar geldiğimizi
varsayalım. 12'ye geldiğimizde 12'nin
karşısındaki nokta hadi tam şuraya denk
getireyim de daha şık gözüksün görüntü.
Şurası da 12 olsun arkadaşım. 12'ye
karşılık gelen noktalar burası mı
olacak? E hocam aradaki yerleri
işaretlemeyecek misin? Aslında birim
zamanda eşit işlem kapasite yapılıyorsa
örneğin 0la 2 arasındaki tüm gerçek
sayılarda da tam karşılığındaki
değerleri almayacak mı bu fonksiyon?
Alacak. O halde grafiği çizerken
doğrusal bir şekilde bak bu şekilde
gittim ama nerede durmasını bilmeliyim?
12'de durmasını bilmeliyim. Nereden
başladım? 0'dan başladım. Olay bu kadar.
Bak çizdiğimiz bu grafik kime aittir?
Yukarıda yazdığımız f(x) = x'e aittir.
Ama sınırları olan bir fonksiyon bu.
0'dan başladım 12'nin hizasında
bıraktım. Birazdan bu sınırların tanım
ve görüntü kümesi ile ilişkili olduğunu
da anlayacağız ama sorular üzerinden
öğreneceğiz bazı şeyleri. Şimdi bakalım
gerçekten bir şeyler öğrendik mi? Bir
ayakkabı firmasının dakikada bir çift
ayakkabı ürettiği biliniyor. Çalışma
süresine dakika x'ler. Üretilen ayakkabı
çiftlerine f(x) diyelim. Hatta
f(x)'lerin neye eşit olduğunu asla
kafandan çıkarmıyorsun. Y'lere yani
koordinat düzleminde gösterirken F diye
bulduğum bütün o değerler aslında senin
için Y değerlidir. Bu firmanın üretimi
ile ilgili elde edilen doğrusal
fonksiyonun grafiği aşağıdaymış. Gel
kontrol edelim. Üretilen ayakkabı çifti
yani y değerleri. Bak doğru yere
yazmışım. Aslında burası y ekseniydi
zaten. Çalışılan süre aslında burası
neydi? X ekseniydi. Örneğin sen 20
dakikanın sonunda grafiğe baktığımda ona
karşılık gelen noktayı tespit ettiğinde
cevap ne olmalı? Hocam nereden bileyim?
Elimde denklem falan yok deme. Aslında
başta yazıyor. Bir ayakkabı firmasının
bir dakikada bir çift ayakkabı ürettiği
biliniyor ve doğrusal olarak bu şekilde
devam ediyor. Bunun Türkçe karşılığı
şudur arkadaş. 1 dakikada bir çift
ayakkabı üretiyor. Devam ediyorum. 2
dakikada 2 çift ayakkabı üretiyor. Nokta
nokta 10 dakikada kaç çift ayakkabı
üretir? Mantıken 10 tane çift ayakkabı
üretir. Devam ettim hocam. 20 dakikaya
geldim. 20 dakikada 20 çift ayakkabı
üretmez mi? Süpersin. O zaman ne
diyorum? A'nın cevabı kesinlikle 20.
Hocam inanılmaz kolay. Mantığı anladın
değil mi? 70 dakikada kaç çift ayakkabı
üretirsin? E mantıken 70 çift ayakkabı
üretirsin. Geldim 100 dakikada kaç çift
ayakkabı üretirsin? 100 çift ayakkabı
üretirsin. Biz aslında grafiği
yorumladık ama aşağıdaki soruya bakalım.
Fonksiyonun cebirsel gösterimi yazar
mısınız? doğrusal fonksiyon olarak
ilerliyor. 1e 1, 2'ye 2, 10a 10, 20'ye
20 şeklinde gidiyorsa bu fonksiyon bizim
bildiğimiz doğrusal referans fonksiyonu
şeklinde gösterilir. Bu neydi? Bir daha
yaz. Doğrusal referans fonksiyonu.
Referans
fonksiyonudur bu. Anlaştık mı? O
fonksiyonun kuralını verdim ben sana.
Şimdi soru benden a + b + c'nin
toplamında istiyor. Onu da buluruz. 100
+ 70 + 20'yi de aldığımda şuranın
toplamı ne yaptı? 90. 100ile
topladığımda cevabımız ne yaptı? 190
yaptı. O halde doğru cevabım A + B + C
ne olacaktır? 190 olacaktır. Vurdum
cevabı. Bu sayfada kafama takılan bazı
noktalar olabilir. Çok normal. Konuya
daha yeni başladık. Bazı kavramları
henüz tam olarak vermedik. Hepsini
ilerleyen süreçte veriyorum. Adım adım
bu dersin içinde bitireceğim. Rahat ol
tabii. Ama önce konuya seni bir
ısındıracak sorularla bir başlamam
lazım. Bir spor salonundaki koşu bandı
sporcunun koştuğu süreye göre harcadığı
kalori miktarını doğrusal olarak
ölçmüştür. Ha normal durumda bu cihazın
yazılımında kullanılan fonksiyon f(x) =
x doğrusal referans fonksiyonudur. Doğru
mu? Yani şunu söylemeye çalışıyor.
Sporcunun koştuğu süreyi kaloriyle
oranlıyor. Yani 1 dakika koştuysa bu
arkadaş bir kalori yakacaktır. Kalori
yakacaktır. 2 dakika koştuysa 2 kalori
yakması lazım. Mantıken böyle ilerlemesi
lazım. Doğru mudur? Ama soruda bize bunu
sormuyor. Bu fonksiyonda x koşulu süreyi
f(x) ise ekranda gösterilen yakılan
kaloriyi gösteriliyor. Yani benim burada
dakika diye yazdıklarım x'tir. Kaloriler
nelerdir? f(x)'lerdir. Süper. FX'lerin
hepsi de y'ye eşitti. Biliyorum
cihazdaki hatadan kaynaklı cihaz
hatalıymış. 15 dakika koşan bir
sporcunun yaktığı kalori 5 olarak
hesaplanmış. Bir dakika bunu yazalım. 15
dakikanın sonunda kaç kalori yakmış? 5
kalori yakmış. Tamam mıyız? Devam ettim.
21 dakika koşunun sonunda kaç kalori
yakmış hocam? 7 kalori yakmış. Süper.
Bunu da anladık. Devam ediyor soru. Buna
göre yakılan gerçek kaloriyi ekranda
göstermek için fonksiyon nasıl
güncellenmelidir? Normalde böyle
ilerleseydi benim fonksiyonumun
gösterimi ne olmalıydı? f(x) = x
olmalıydı. Ama ne oluyor? Ben x yerine
hocam 15 yazdığımda f(x)'in cevabı ne
çıkmış?
5 çıkmış. Peki bir düşün bakalım kaçta
kaçıdır hocam? 3'e bölmüşüz aslında
değil mi? Peki bu durum bütün durumlar
için devam ediyor mu? Kontrol ediyorum.
21 dakikanın sonunda kaça çıkmış kalori
yakımı? 7'ye çıkmış. Aslında yine
harcanan sürenin kaçta kaçı yakmışım?
1/çte bir yakmışım. Peki gel. Gerçekten
anlayıp anlamadığımızı şu an ölçeceğimiz
noktadayız. Yeni bir fonksiyon
tanımlıyorum. Bu fonksiyon çünkü
bozulmuş diyor bu makine ve farklı
biçimde yakmaya başlamış. Normalde fx =
x şeklinde yakmasını bekliyorduk. Yani
1e 1, 2'ye 2, 10'a 10, 15'e 15 gibi ama
1/te bir yakmış. Yani her bir x'in
1/3te'i kadar yakabiliyor. Misal ben
buraya gelsem 30 dakikanın sonunda ne
kadar kalori yaktı diye sana sorsam
artık güncel fonksiyonda yerine yazmak
zorundasın. Gx yerine 10 yazdım. Cevap
Eş 30/3'ten pardon 30 için kontrol
ediyorduk. 30 dakikanın sonunda 30/3'ten
kaç kalori yaktığını anlıyorum. He hocam
10 kalori yakmış bu arkadaş. Çünkü bu
fonksiyon bozulmuş ya da makine
bozulmuş. Fonksiyon bozulur mu? Kuralı
bu şekilde güncellenmelidir.
Bak ne yaptım? Referans fonksiyonundan
yeni bir fonksiyon elde ettim. Onu
referans alarak 1/çte birine götürdü
hep. O zaman f(x) = x değil de g(x) =
x/3 şeklinde bir fonksiyon tanımlanmış
burada. Devam. Şimdi artık yavaş yavaş
referans fonksiyonunu ayrıntılarına
girmeye başlıyoruz. İlk olarak
fonksiyonlarda bağımlı değişken bağımsız
değişkenin aldığı değerlere göre
değişir. Bunu söylemiştik. Burada
x'lerimiz neydi? Bağımsız değişkenlerdi.
Y'lerimiz ya da diğer adıyla
f(x)'lerimiz neydi? Bağımlı
değişkenlerimizdi. Kime bağlıydı? X'e
bağlı değerler alıyordu. Ki bizim
referans fonksiyonumuz kimdi? y = f(x) o
da eş x. Referans fonksiyonunda bağımsız
değişkenler x, bağımlı değişkenler y =
f(x)'lerdi. 1 yazdığımda 1'i, 2
yazdığımda 2, 3 yazdığımda beni nereye
götürüyor? 3'e götürüyor. O halde ben bu
referans fonksiyonunun grafiğini
çizebilir miyim? Gel burada ben grafiği
çözeyim. Yine hani bazı acele eden
arkadaşlar olacaktır. Hocam grafiği daha
böyle ayrıntı çizeceğim. Hepsini
çizeceğim ama adım adım ilerliyoruz.
Hocam 1de nereye gidiyorsun? 1'e
gidiyorsun. 2'de nereye gidiyorsun?
Dikkat et. 2'ye gidiyorsun. Bak tek tek
noktaları gösteriyorum. 3'te nereye
gidiyorsun? 3'e gidiyorsun. Doğru mudur?
Eğer ki ben bütün reel sayılarda
çalışıyorsam yani x yerine istediğim
değeri verebiliyorsam evet bu noktalar
üzerindeki her şeyi alabilirim ama bu
noktalardan daha küçük hatta negatif
değerler de alabilirim. Aslında referans
fonksiyonunun grafiği f(x) = x'in
grafiği bu şekildedir. Birazdan bunun
ayrıntısını göreceğiz ama referans
fonksiyonunun nasıl gözüktüğü ile ilgili
burada fikir sahibi olduk. Şimdi altta
sorumuz yoktu değil mi? Yoktu. Geldim 4.
soruya. Sen doğrusal referans
fonksiyonunun kuralı nedir dediğimde
direkt bana şunu yazabiliyorsan buradaki
soruları çok rahat çözeceğiz. Şimdi
doğrusal referans fonksiyonu dediğimizde
referans ama doğrusal bu önemli. Çünkü
başka fonksiyonların da referansı var.
Doğrusal referans
fonksiyonu yazdığımda senin bana sadece
şunu yazabilmen yeterli. f(x) = x'e
benzemek zorunda. Hocam şimdi bak
soruya. Gerçek sayılar kümesi üzerinde
tanımla. Mehmet hoca söylemişti. Her
fonksiyonun bir tanım kümesi olması
lazımdı. Bir de görüntü kümesi olması
lazımdı. Tanım kümesine x'leri, görüntü
kümesine y'leri yazıyorduk. reel
sayılarda, gerçek sayılarda tanımlı
dediği andan itibaren aslında reel
sayıları reel sayılarla eşleştiriyorum
demektir. f(x) = a + 3 x x fonksiyonu
nasıl bir fonksiyonmuş? Doğrusal
referans fonksiyonuymuş. Buna göre a
değeri kaçtır? Arkadaş doğrusal referans
fonksiyonu kime benzemek zorundaydı?
f(x) = x'e benzemek zorundaydı. X'in
önündeki buradaki katsayı kaç? Biz
görmesek bile her daim 1. Madem bu
fonksiyon bununla aynı fonksiyon o zaman
ben şunu söylerim. Hocam benim
fonksiyonum ki bana verilen burada a + 3
x x aslında orada ne yazıyor? 1 x x
yazıyor. Yani x'in önündeki katsayı
kesinlikle kaç olabilmek zorunda? Olmak
zorunda. 1 olmak zorunda. A + 3'ü 1'e
eşitlersem demek ki a yerine kaç
yazmalıyım? 1 - 3'ten cevabım ne geldi?
-2 geldi. Eğer referans fonksiyonun
tanımı ile ilgili bir soru gelirse o
soru buna benzeyebilir. A kolay bir soru
ama gel biraz zorlaştıralım o soruyu.
Öyle kolay sorularla olmaz. Yine gerçel
sayılar kümesi üzerinde tanımla.
Mantığını anlattım. Gerçel sayıların
birazdan o tanım görüntü kümeleri
anlatacağım kızı. Sakin sakin
anlatacağım. Şimdi soruda şu cümle
kesinlikle geçmek zorunda bizim
çözebilmemiz için. y = f(x) doğrusal
referans fonksiyonu biçiminde
tanımlanıyor. Eğer doğrusal referans
fonksiyonu diyorsa o fonksiyon
kesinlikle ama kesinlikle buna benzemek
zorunda. Buna göre FA, FB - FC
değerlerini bul. Mesela ben hep
söylüyorum ya matematik tanımla yapılır.
Eğer tanımı bilmiyorsa bir öğrenci
istediğin kadar iyi matematik bilir.
Dört işlem bilamazsın bu soruyu. Ama ben
tanımı biliyorum. Şimdi bakıyorum. Bu
fonksiyon buna benziyor mu? Allah aşkına
benzemiyor değil mi? Neden benzemiyor
hocam? Senin fonksiyonunun içerisinde
x²are var. O tarafta yok. O zaman
buradaki x²eden kurtul. Matematikte
buradaki x²eden kurtulmak istiyorsan
eğer ki önüde değişken değerler
alabiliyorsa demek ki aslında 0'la
çarpıyorum. Neden? fx = 0 x x² ne
demektir? gitti demektir. Burası 0 oldu
demektir. Kurtuldun ondan demektir. O
halde aslında soru bana a - 2'nin 0'a
eşit olduğunu yazmamı istiyor. Buradan
a'yı 2 olarak bulmamı istiyor. Bunu
anladık mı? Devam. Hocam benim elimde b
+ 1 x x var. X terimi oluyor muydu?
Oluyordu. Ama önündeki katsayı kaç olmak
zorundaydı? 1. O halde benim burada x'in
önündeki katsayıyı kaça eşitlemem
gerekiyor? 1'e. b + 1 neye eşit olmalı?
Hop! 0'a değil 1'e eşit olmalı. 1'i at
karşıya. Demek ki B'nin cevabı neymiş
hocam? 0mış. Anladık mı B'yi de?
Anladık. Geldim hocam. Bu ne böyle? Bu
sabit değerdir. Yanında x'li mixli terim
var mı? Yok. Misal ben bu fonksiyonun
sonuna + 0 yazsam fonksiyonun işlemin
sonucu kuralı değişir mi? Değişmez.
Demek ki ben bu 0ı eşitlersem burayı
buradaki c -3'ten kurtulurum. Benim tek
derdim. Eğer ki bu doğrusal referans
fonksiyonuysa buna benzetmek. Benzetmek
için elimden geleni yaptım. Dedim ki
hocam demek ki buradaki C -3 değeri de
0'a eşit. C'nin de değeri 3 gelmek
zorunda. Mesela bak bu değerleri yerine
yazayım mı sana göstereyim? Biraz
uzatıyorum ama olsun. 2 - 2 a yerine 2
yazdım. X x² + b yerine ne yazdık? 0
yazdık. 0 + 1 x x + c yerine 3 yazdık.
Yanında x3 var. Gerçekten kontrol
ediyorum hocam. Bak burası 0 geldi. 0'la
çarptığım için burası 0 oldu. Yani
burası komple gitti. Buradan sadece 1x
geldi. 3'ten 3 çıktı 0 kaldı. Son halini
yazıyorum. f(x) = x. Benzedi mi? Benzedi
ama soru benden bunu istemiyor. F2'yi
bul diyor. A yerine 2 yazıyorum. Şurada
FA'yı bulacağım. F2 oldu. Referans
fonksiyonu herkesi kime götürüyor?
Aslında kendine götürüyor. F2'nin cevabı
2ymiş. Geldim. B yerine 0 yazıyorum. B
yerine 0 yazarsam F0'ın cevabı ne gelir?
0. Referans fonksiyonunda 0 0'a gider.
Güzel. Geldim. C yerine 3 yazıyorum. O
da beni nereye götürecek? F3'e. F3'ün
cevabı nedir? 3'tür. Soru tüm bunların
bizden toplamını işte farkını falan
istiyor. Onları bir yazalım bakalım. 2 +
0. Bak 2'yi buldum. 0'ı buldum. 3'ü
buldum. İşlemi yaptığımda cevap tamam.
Ekki ver1 geldi. Bence olay bu soruyla
tam olarak anlaşıldı. Anlaşıldı. Ama ya
farklı soru gelirse arkadaş her soru
tipine hazırlıklı olmalıyız. İşte burada
da tam da o var. 6. örnekteyim. Analitik
düzlemde f(x) doğrusal bir fonksiyon ama
doğrusal olması yetmez. Eksik kalır.
Doğrusal referans fonksiyonunun grafiği
üzerinde verilen iki noktaymış. Şimdi
aşağıda bir nokta verilmiş. Doğrusal
referans fonksiyonunun üzerinde dediği
an kimin üzerinde aslında bu hocam? f(x)
= x'in üzerinde. Bunu anladın mı?
Aslında f(x) dediğinde her ifadede ne
vardır? Y vardır. Aslında bak buranın
Türkçe karşılığı ne oldu biliyor musun?
X e= ne çıktı? Y çıktı. Güzel.
Ben bu doğrusal referans fonksiyonunun
üzerinde bir nokta alıyorum. Doğrusal
referans fonksiyonunun tahmini grafiğini
çiziyoruz. Hatırla şöyle çizmiştim. Ahan
da böyle. f(x) = x. Bunun üzerinde
aldığın bütün noktalar için örneğin
hocam bu noktada m yazıyorsa M
yazmayayım hadi kafalar karışmasın
yukarıdakiyle K yazıyorsa buna karşılık
gelen Y değeri de kesinlikle ne olmalı?
K olmalı. Bak bu fonksiyonun grafiği
üzerinde A noktası aldım. A noktasının
x'i de y'si de birbirine ne çıkmak
zorunda? Eşit çıkmak zorunda. Ben bu
mantığı öğrenirsem bu soruyu çözerim.
Hocam bu doğrusal referans fonksiyonun
üzerinde bir noktaysa verilen şu değer x
değeridir. Şu değer y değeridir. Aslında
x ile y'nin ne olması gerekir? Eşit
olması gerekir ki bu doğrusal referans
fonksiyonunun üzerinde bir nokta olsun.
M + 3 = 7 - m. M'yi bu tarafa aldım. 2m
3'ü karşıya attım. Her tarafı 2'ye
böldüm. M'nin cevabı 2. Geldim tekrardan
B noktası da grafik üzerindeymiş. O
halde bunlar x değeri, bunlar y değeri.
Çok net biliyorum ki 3m - n değeri m +
3n'ye eşit olacak. Ben bir önce m'leri
bir tarafa taşıyayım. N'leri bir tarafa
taşıyayım. Burada ne elde ettim? 4 tane
n elde ettim. Burada ne elde ettim? 2
tane m elde ettim. Biz m'yi ne
bulmuştuk? 2. 2 x 2 = 4 x n'yile
karşının tamamı sadeleşti. O zaman n'nin
cevabına ne kaldı? 1 kaldı. Fakat soru
benden FM + N'yi soruyor. Bak, FM + N.
M'yi ne buldun? 2 buldun. N'yi ne
buldun? 1 buldun. Soru aslında hepsini
geçtim kenara. Soru sana F3'ü soruyor.
Fonksiyonu doğrusal referans
fonksiyonuysa x yerine ne yazarsan yaz
cevap ne çıkacak? Oradaki değerin ta
kendisi çıkmak zorunda. O halde F3'ün
cevabı da F3'e eşit olmak zorundadır.
Bence konu net şekilde anlaşılıyor. Sen
de şimdi modül fasikülünde 4. sayfa
bitti. Tek ne yapıyorduk? Bütün
sayfalara tik atıyorduk seninle
birlikte. O tikleri atmaya devam
ediyoruz. Geldim 7. soruya. Bakalım
öğreniyor muyuz? Bir lise robotik
kulübün Allah ekranım karardı benim. Bir
saniye. Bir lise robotik kulübünün
tasarladığı robotla ilgili aşağıdakiler
bilinmektedir. Robot sabit hızla hareket
ediyor. Hızı sürekli değişken değil.
Sabit bir hızla gidiyor. Dakikada 1
metre yol alıyor. Bu cümle bence önemli.
Sabit hızla gidiyor ve dakikada 1 metre
yol alıyorsa örneğin 1 dakikada kaç
metre yol alır? 1 metre yol alır. 2
dakikaya geldiğimizde kaç metre yol
almış olur? 2 metre. Nokta nokta. Hocam
10 dakikaya geldik. Kaç metre yol alır?
10 metre yol alır. Tamam bunları yazdım.
Tam dolu batarya ile robot 20 dakika
hareket edebiliyormuş. Bu da önemli bir
nokta. Geldiği son yer neresi? 20
dakika. 20 dakikanın sonunda aslında kaç
metre yol alacak? 20 metre yol alacak.
Buna göre soruları gel beraber
cevaplayalım. Şimdi robotun hareketi
fonksiyon olarak modelleyip C1 ile
yazınız. Robotun hareketine baktığımda
1'e 1, 2'ye 2, 10'a 10 20'ye 20 şeklinde
gidiyor ya. Her seferinde x'e ne
verirsem ki bunlar benim x'lerimdi.
Bunlar benim fx'lerimdi. Aslında
f(x)'ler de y'ye eşitti. X'ler y'lere
eşit çıkıyor. Aslında bu da nedir?
Doğrusal referans fonksiyonunun ta
kendisidir. Demek ki f(x) kime eşit
olacak? X'e eşit olacak. Burayı anladık
mı? Doğrusal referans fonksiyonunu
anlatmaya çalışmış. Yukarıdaki
problemde. Bana ben modelledim onu.
Kuralını oluşturdum. Şimdi bu kuraldan
yola çıkarak diyor ki bana aşağıda
tabloda boş bırakılan yerleri bağımsız
değişken x süre olmak üzere bağımlı
değişken f(x)'ler yol olmak üzere bu
değerleri doldurunuz" diyor. Biz de keza
zaten öyle kabul etmiştik. Dikkat et.
Burada x'leri dakika süre kabul
etmiştik. Burada da metre olarak yani
yol olarak kabul etmiştik. Şimdi sen
fonksiyonun ne olduğunu biliyorsun.
Kuralını biliyorsun. X yerine 0 yazarsan
f(x)'in cevabı ne çıkar? 0. X yerine 2
yazarsan cevap ne çıkar? 2. 7/2 yazarsan
ne çıkar? 7/2. Hocam böyle yarımlı
buçuklu bütün reel sayıları
verebilirsin. Özel olarak söylemediyse.
Tamam mı? Bütün reel sayıları vereceğiz.
Doğrusal referans fonksiyonunda geldim.
9. Eğer bak burası kritik hocam aslında
f(x)'in cevabı ne gelmiş? 9. Cevabı 9sa
yani 9 metre yol alıyorsa bunu kaç
dakikada alır hocam? 9 dakikada alır.
X'ini bulmamı istemiş. Terse gittik.
Peki 12 dakikada kaç metre yol alır? 12
met. 20 metre yol aldığına göre kaç
dakika yol almıştır? 20 dakika. Tüm bu
tabloyu böylelikle doldurdum. Yola
devam. Fonksiyonun cebirsel gösterimi ve
doldurduğunuz tablo yardımıyla
fonksiyonun grafiğini analitik düzlemde
çiziniz. Şimdi burada doğrusal referans
fonksiyonunu çizeceğim ama doğrusal
referans fonksiyonu nerede tanımlıydı?
Normal şartlarda hocam bütün gerçek
sayılarda tanımlıydı. Yani x yerine ne
istersen yazabiliyordun. Ona da karşılık
yerleri bu grafik üzerinde buluyorduk.
Bak, fonksiyonun grafiği üzeri
noktalardan oluşur. Sonsuz tane noktalar
kümesinden oluşuyor. O noktaların her
birini temsilen f(x) e= x'i
kullanıyorum. Doğrusal referans
fonksiyonunda. Anlaştık mı? Şimdi benim
doğrusal referans fonksiyonum nereden
başlayacak? -3 dakika diye bir tabiri
var mı? Yok. 0'dan başladı. 1ci dakikaya
geldiğimde 1 metre yol aldığımda nereye
geldim? F1'e geldim. 20 metre yol
aldığımda aslında nereye gelmiştim? 20
dakikaya gelmiştim. Doğru mu? Demek ki
en son varacağım nokta da burası olacak.
Bak siyahla göstereyim bu sefer grafiğim
aslında bu kadarcık. Siyahla gösterdiğim
grafik benim grafiğimdir. Geçtiği
noktalar göstersen de göstermesen de
önemli değil ama bitiş noktalarını
göstermek zorundayım. Bu da benim f(x) =
x kuralıyla gösterdiğim fonksiyonumdur.
Anlaştık mı? Şimdi birazdan tanımlarını
vereceğim şeye ufaktan soruyla giriş
yapıyoruz. Tam da yeni marif modelin
bizden istediği gibi. Nasıl bir soru
hocam? Fonksiyonun hangi bağımsız
değişkeni için? Bağımsız değişken demek
unutmuyorsun. X'ler demekti. Hangi
bağımsız değişkeni için 0a eşit olduğunu
bulunuz. Bak hangi bağımsız değişken
bilmiyorum ama cevabın ne gelmesini
istiyorum? 0. Peki bunun anlamı neydi?
Metreydi değil mi? Şu taraf metreydi. Şu
taraf yani x'ler süreydi yani
dakikalarımızdı. 0 metreyi kaç dakikada
alır bu arkadaş? 0 dakikada. Demek ki x
= 0 için bu fonksiyonun f0'ın cevabı
neydir? 0'dır. Aslında bana şunu
soruyor. Bak hangi bağımsız değişken
için x = 0 için fonksiyonun değeri
0'dır. Birazdan bunu şöyle
tanımlayacağız. Fonksiyonun 0ırları yani
cevabının 0 çıktığı x değerlerini
soruyor demek.
Donmadı. Sindirmeni bekliyorum. Hatta
bir yudumda su alayım burada. Susadım
vallahi. Var.
Şükür. Devam. Bak şimdi geldim E'ye.
Fonksiyonun değerlerinin en küçük yani
minimum ve en büyük değerlerini yazınız.
Şunu istiyor benden. Bu fonksiyonun
değerleri dediğimizde nelerini
kastediyoruz? f(x) = x yazıyorduk. Doğru
mu? Ya da f(x)'ler aslında neye eşitti?
Y'ye eşitti. Buradaki x'ler bağımsız
değişkenlerdi. Bunlar bağımlı
değişkenlerdi. Ama aynı zamanda
fonksiyonun değerlerini bulmuş
oluyorsun. Burada fonksiyonun değeri
dediğimde burada çıkan sonuç aslında
yine x'e eşit. Hepsinde onu biliyoruz
zaten. Ama bu fonksiyonun ilk başlangıç
noktası neresiydi? 0'dı. f0'da 0'a mı
gitti? Örneğin f1'de nereye gitti? 1'e
gitti. F2'de nereye gitti? 2'ye gitti.
Nokta nokta. En son kaça kadar gelmiştim
ben süre olarak? 20'ye. Çünkü 20
dakikanın sonunda fonksiyonumuz ya da
robotumuzun bataryası bitmiş. Bu arkadaş
20 metre yol almıştı. O halde net olarak
şunu söyleyebilirim. Bu fonksiyonun en
küçük değeri dediği için 0'ı
işaretliyorum. Bu en küçük değeridir.
Yani minimum değeridir. En büyük değeri
dediği için daha büyük bir değer var mı
yolda giderken? Yok. Doğrusal olarak
artıyor çünkü. O zaman en büyük değerini
de burada aldı. Yani bu fonksiyonun
maksimum ve minimum noktalarını bulunuz
dediğinde, değerlerini bulunuz dediğinde
yapacağın işlemi anlamış olduk burada.
Şimdi bu anlattıklarım evet sorular
üzerinden bir yere kadar. Hocam sen bana
bu işin mantığını artık anlatır mısın?
Fonksiyon dediğimizde aklımızda
canlanması gereken her şeyi tam olarak
bu noktada anlatacağım. Lütfen elinden
kalemi, kağıdı bir dakika bırakır mısın?
Kitabın önünde açık beklesin. Beklesin.
Gözünle takip et. Yeri geldiğinde bir
tur ben anlatayım doldurayım. Tamam mı?
Bak senden bunu istiyorum. Sonrasında
sen yap işlemleri. Sen doldur. Videoyu
durdurup sen doldur. Oldu mu? Bunu
gerçekten yapmanı istiyorum. Lütfen
burada uymaya çalış. Mesela hep diyorum
ya özel ders konsepti gibi ilerliyoruz
biz bu kitapta. Sen açtın kitabını
koydun önüne. Hocam evet. Ben derim ki
gel bak ben bir tur üstünde şöyle
yazayım. Sildim abi. Şimdi sen. Tamam
mı? Şimdi senin doldurmanı bekliyorum.
Tam o noktadayız.
Tanım kümesi, görüntü kümesi,
fonksiyonun 0'ı, fonksiyonun işareti
hepsini burada öğreniyoruz. Bir
fonksiyonun, bağımsız değişkenlerin, bir
dakika bağımsız değişkenler kimlerdi
hocam? X'lerdi. Bağımsız değişkenlerinin
alabileceği tüm değişkenlerin
oluşturduğu kümeye tanım kümesi adı
verilir. Tanım kümesi
olarak adlandırılır. Demek ki hani biz
x'leri alıyorduk, y'lere götürüyorduk
ya. Buradaki x'lerimiz aslında artık
isim olarak adlandırılırsa adı ne
olacakmış? tanım kümesi olacakmış. Bunu
da anlaştık mı? Güzel. Geldim
ikincisine. Bak artık tanımları
veriyorum. Yani bağımsız değişkenlerde
seçebileceğim bütün elemanların kümesine
tanım kümesi deniyormuş. Tanım
kümesindeki her bir bağımsız değişkene
karşılık gelen bağımlı değişkenlerin bak
bağımlı değişkenlerin oluşturduğu kümeye
ise değer kümesi adı verilir. Değer
kümesi ya da görüntü kümesi adı verilir.
Değer kümesi ya da biz görüntü kümesi
diyelim. Hiç değer kümesini
karıştırmayalım. Burada görüntü kümesi
adı verilir. Görüntü kümesi. Yani
görüntülerini bulmuş oluyoruz biz
burada. Oldu mu? Ne yaptın hocam? Bir
daha göster. X'leri alıp Y'lerle
eşleştiriyorduk. Buradaki bizdeki
bağımlı değişkenler dediğimiz kimlerdi?
Y'lerdi. Buradaki Y'ler artık ne olarak
adlandırılacak? Görüntü kümesinin
elemanları olarak adlandırılacak. Peki
ben görüntü kümesinin elemanlarını nasıl
bulacağım hocam? X değişkenlerini
fonksiyonun kuralında yerine yazacağım.
Elde ettiğim bütün elemanlar görüntü
kümesi elemanı olacak. Süper. Peki
geldim başka bir şey daha. Hatta biraz
önce soru üzerinde de kullandık bunu.
Bağımlı değişkeni yani y değeri 0 yapan
yani fonksiyonun değerini 0 yapan
anlamında şöyle yazmıştık hatırla.
Fonksiyonun değeri. Bak şurası
fonksiyonun değeridir. Değeri. Benimle
birlikte bu notları sonrasında
alacaksın. Fonksiyonun değerini 0 yapan
x değerine ne denir hocam dediğimde
bağımlı değişkeni 0 yapan bağımsız
değişkene ki kendisi x'ti. Fonksiyonun
0ı denir. 0ı denir. Hadi onları da büyük
harfle yazayım. Fonksiyonun 0ı denir.
Bana fonksiyonun 0'ını bul dediğimde
fonksiyonun kuralını 0'a eşitliyorsun.
Ne demek hocam? Şimdi f(x) = x doğru
referans fonksiyonu. Bu fonksiyonun
0'ını bul dediğimde bunu alıp 0'a
eşitliyorsun. ax = 0. Bitti oğlum. Çok
kolay la hocam bu diyeceksin. Ama şimdi
ilerleyen derste şunu anlatacağım ben
sana. Diyeceğim ki f(x) = 3x + 6 bizim
doğrusal fonksiyonumuz. Bak doğrusal
referans demiyorum. Buradan türettiğimiz
bir fonksiyon. Ama bu fonksiyonun 0'ını
bul dediğimde demek ki kuralı neye
eşitliyorum? 0'a eşitliyorum. Aslında
kimi 0'a eşitliyorum? Y değerini 0'a
eşitliyorum. Burası aslında y değeri.
Y'yi 0'a eşitleyince x'i bulmam
gerekiyor. Aa denklem çözeceğim hocam. E
denklem çözmeyi biliyorsun. 6'yı karşıya
attım. -6. Her tarafı 2'ye böldüm.
-2'ymiş. Demek ki bu fonksiyonun 0ı x =
-2. Fonksiyonun 0ı demek x yerine -2
yazarsan cevap 0 geliyor demek. O 0a
sebep olan x değeri kim? -2. Artık
fonksiyonun 0ının ne demek olduğunu da
öğrendik. Oh. Tane tane adım adım bütün
tanımları öğrenerek tanım bilirsen
matematik yaparsın. Çok zeki olmanı
istemiyorum abi. Bana çok zeki öğrenci
gerekmiyor. Bana tanımı öğrenen
öğrenciyi ver. Ben ona matematikteki
bütün konuları rahat rahat anlatırım.
f(x) = 0 eşitliğini sağlayan x değerleri
fonksiyonun 0'ıdır. Bitti.
Peki bir fonksiyonun işareti demek ne
demektir? Fonksiyonun değerlerinin
pozitif ya da negatif olduğu yerler ya
da 0 olduğu yerler incelenirken
fonksiyonun 0ı referans alınır. Neden
hocam? Çünkü örneğin bizim elimizde
doğrusal referans fonksiyonu olsun. O
doğrusal referans fonksiyonunun
grafiğini çizdik hatırlarsan burada.
Hatırlıyorsun değil mi? Kaça kaç
geliyordu mesela? Bak 1'e 1 gelen nokta,
2'ye 2 gelen nokta. Tabii ki ben bunları
hep tam sayı seçiyorum ama aradaki
değeri de alabilirim. Örneğin √2
değerini aldım. Buna karşılık gelen
değerde ne olmak zorunda? √2 gelmek
zorunda. Eğer ki reel sayılar pardon
gerçek sayılarda tanımlıysa referans
fonksiyonu ki orada tanımlı olmak
zorunda. √2 alabilirim. Ama biz kolaylık
olması adına hep bu tam sayıları
seçiyoruz. Onu da söylemiş olayım
burada. Şimdi bu doğrusal referans
fonksiyonunda şurası fonksiyonun
nesiydi? 0ıydı değil mi? Burada çünkü
fonksiyonuma x yerine 0 verdiğimde cevap
ne geldi? 0 geldi. Peki bana şunu söyle.
Fonksiyon burada değeri ne geldi? 1 yani
pozitif. Burada ne geldi? 2. Pozitif.
Pozitif. Demek ki fonksiyon bu bölgede
artık nasıl değerler alıyor? 0dan büyük
değerler alıyor. Hocam hangi bölge
orası? Onun tamamını ben yeşille
çizeyim. Bak 0'dan büyük değerler aldığı
yer x ekseninin üstünde kalan yerler.
Hayır.
Fonksiyonun 0ını bulduk ya. 0ının
referans fonksiyonunda sağ tarafında
kalan grafik. Her zaman sağında kalmışız
ama referans fonksiyonumuz da sağında
kalan. Peki geldim hocam 0ın solunda
kalan bu bölgede fonksiyonun değerlerini
söyler misiniz? Fonksiyonun değerleri
kimlerdi? Y'lerdi. Bak fonksiyonun
değeri burada göstereyim. -1 verdiğimde
x yerine y değeri ne geldi? -1. X yerine
-2 verdiğimde cevap değer ne geldi? -2.
Hep burada nasıl değerler almaya
başladım? Negatif değerler almaya
başladım. He hocam şimdi olay anlaşıldı.
O zaman bu fonksiyonun 0dan küçük olduğu
değerler neresidir? X ekseninin altında
kaldığı kısımlardır. Fonksiyonun bütün
değerleri ki fonksiyonun değerlerini
f(x) ile gösteriyorum.
0'dan küçük değerler alır. Anlaştık mı?
Bak bir tek grafik üzerinden ne kadar
çok muhabbet dönebiliyor. Peki o zaman
biraz bunu netleştirelim. Bizim doğrusal
referans fonksiyonumuzun 0ı bilindiği
için şunu net söyleyebilirim. 1 bu
fonksiyonun hocam x değeri 0'dan
küçükken f(x) değerleri de pardon x
değeri 0'dan büyükken ki bak x değerleri
buradan 0'dan büyük gelen y değerlerinin
hepsi yani f(x)'lerin hepsi ne oldu?
0'dan büyük oldu. X değerleri 0'dan
küçükken f(x)'lerin de değerlere her
daim nasıl değerler geldi? 0'dan küçük
geldi. Gerçekten ben x'lerimi buradan
seçtim. Negatif değerler. Ona karşılık
gelen değerler hep nasıl geldi?
negatif olarak geldi. Biz bunu tabloya
dökmeyi öğrenmeliyiz. Tablo aşağıda var
ama ben yine de bir daha çizeceğim.
Aslında bu tablo ne biliyor musun? Sayı
doğrusu abiciğim. Sayı doğrusunu çiz.
Kim için çiziyorum? X için çiziyorum.
Sola doğru gidersem ne olur? Eksi
sonsuz. Sağa doğru gidersem ne olur?
Artı sonsuz. Bu fonksiyonun 0ı
neresidir? Bu fonksiyon x yerine 0
yazdığımda değeri de ne geliyor? 0
geliyor. Peki fonksiyonun değeri yani
şurada f(x)'leri
x değer ya da onu şöyle gösterelim
artık. Şurada x'lerimi ayırıyorum.
Şurası da f(x)'lerin değeri olsun. Şu
üst kat x'lerin değeri. Bak x burada 0,
x burada 0'dan küçük değerler alıyor.
Dikkat edersen x'in değeri burada nedir?
0'dan küçük. X'in değeri bu tarafta
nedir? 0'ın sağı ve solu olmak üzere
0'dan büyüktür. Fonksiyonum 0dan küçük
değerlerde 0ın solunda nasıl değerler
aldı? Negatif değerler aldı. İşaret
tablosu yapıyorum. A negatif değerler
aldı diyorsun hocam. Artı yapıyorsun.
Eksi yaptım. 0'ın sağında nasıl değerler
aldı fonksiyonum? Pozitif değerler aldı.
Bu tablo inanılmaz önemli bir tablo. Bu
tablo fonksiyonun işaret tablosudur.
Fonksiyonun
işaret tablosu. Ben sana bir fonksiyonun
işaret tablosunu yap dediğimde bunu
yapman gerekecek. Ve bizim 1. dönem 2.
yazılarda fonksiyonların, doğrusal
fonksiyonların işaret tabloları var
müfredatımızda ve bu tabloları bizden
çizmemizi isteyecek. Ha doğrusal
referans fonksiyonu için sabit. Sadece
bunu çizmem yeterli. Fonksiyon
değiştikçe işaret tablosu değişecek.
Hepsini öğreneceğiz adım adım. Ama bence
buraya kadar her şey güzel anlaşıldı.
Ama öğrendiğimizi artık kullanma vakti.
8. soru. Matematik dersinde yeni bir
fonksiyon öğrenen Duru ve Bella arasında
aşağıdaki konuşma geçiyor. Duru diyor
ki, "Süper anladım ya ben bu olayı
diyor. Tıpkı senin gibi. Bu fonksiyona
ben dürüst fonksiyon adını vereceğim
dedi. Öbürü de şaşırıyor Bella. Oğlum
diyor bunun adı diyor doğrusal referans
kızım diyor bunun adı diyor doğrusal
referans fonksiyonu kanka sen ne
diyorsun diyor. Öbürü de diyor ki ya
arkadaş baksana diyor bu fonksiyonun içi
dışı 1 diyor. İçinde ne varsa dışında da
oluyor diyor. Şimdi Bella olayı anlamaya
çalışıyor. f(x) = x'ti ya ya arkadaş
içinde ne varsa cevap ne çıktı? Dışı da
aynı çıktı. Hatta diyor duru gel ben
sana birkaç örnek daha vereyim. Doğrusal
referans fonksiyonda F1'in cevabı ne
çıktı? 1 çıktı. F23'ün cevabı ne çıkar
diyor? Doğrusal referansta 23 çıkar
diyor. İçine ne yazdıysam değeri de
karşılığı da o çıktı. Ben diyor o yüzden
buna dürüst fonksiyon dedim diyor. Tamam
mı? Haklısın diyor. Tanım kümesindeki
her elemanın görüntü kümesinde cevabı da
hep ne oluyor? Kendisi oluyor. A süper.
Bir daha yazıyorum. Bak şimdi. Şurası
neydi? Tanım kümesiydi. Burası neydi?
Görüntü kümesiydi. Görüntü kümesiydi.
Biz tanım kümesindeki elemanları görüntü
kümesindeki elemanlarla eşleştiriyorduk.
X'lerdi, Y'lerdi. 1 verince cevap ne
geldi? 1. 2 verince cevap ne geldi? 2.
Nokta nokta 23 verince cevap ne geldi?
23. Herkesi aslında kime götürdü? Yine
kendisine götürdü. He, güzel. O zaman
diyor bu diyaloğa bakarak bizden şunu
istiyorlar. Fonksiyonun cebirsel
gösterimini yapar mısınız? E hocam bu
fonksiyonun cebirsel gösterimi tanıdık.
Kimdir bu? Doğrusal referans
fonksiyonunun aslında ta kendisidir. İçi
dışı bir fonksiyon gibi. Devam ettim.
Yukarıdaki diyalogda bahsedilen
fonksiyon ki kendisi doğrusal referans
fonksiyonu gerçek sayılarda tanımlı
olsun. Gerçek sayılarda tanımlı demek
tanım kümesini nereden seçtim? Reel
sayılardan. Görüntü kümesi artık nereden
çıkacak? O da reel sayılardan çıkacak. M
ve N de birer gerçek sayı olmak üzere
bunu sağlayan n değerini bulunuz diyor.
Şimdi hocam bu soruyu nasıl çözeceğiz?
Lütfen bu soruya zor deme. Bak ben
yukarıda misal şöyle yazsaydım eğer F23
yazsaydım eğer cevaba ne diyecektin? F23
diyecektin. Doğru mu? 2 x FM + FM + N
bilmem neler falan. Geç onu abi. Tek
başına şunu bir inceleyelim önce. Bu ne
demek hocam? FM + N. Hocam bu doğrusal
fonksiyonda x yerine ne yazmışlar? M + N
yazmışlar. O halde cevap da ne çıkmak
zorunda? M + N. İçi dışı 1di ya. O halde
bunun cevabı nedir? M + N. Misal
yanındaki fonksiyona bak hemen. FM.
FM'nin cevabı ne çıkmak zorunda? M. İçi
dışı 1 hocam. Karşı tarafta FM + 4 var.
FM deyince de oyun aklıma geliyor ya.
Yenisi de çıktı bu arada da. Neyse
günlerimizi veriyoruz yoksa onu.
Oynayanlar var mı bilmiyorum ama
bataklık gibi ab bu oyun var ya.
Çıkamıyorsun. Şimdi bu da m + 4'e eşit.
Yerlerine yazalım. 2 x m + n - m e= m +
4'e. Tamam mıyız? Dağıt 2'yi içeriye.
Hocam buradan 2m geldi. Buradan 2n
geldi. -m = karşı tarafta m + 4. M'lerin
hepsini bu tarafa atalım biz. 2m + 2n -m
vardı. -m daha geldi. -2m = + 4. a + 2m
- 2m birbirini götürdü. 2n = 4. Her
tarafı 2'ye böldüğümde n'nin cevabı ne
olarak bulundu? 2 olarak bulundu ki soru
da benden sadece buradaki n değerinin
değerini istiyordu. Cevabını istiyordu.
Güzel. İlerlemeye devam. Hani dedim ya
doğrusal referans fonksiyonunda ki
kendisi böyle çiziliyor. İstediğimiz
aralıkta çizebiliyorduk bu doğrusal
referans fonksiyonunu. Bu adam özellikle
doğrusal referans fonksiyonunun
grafiğini çizdim diyor ama bak x'leri
nerede başlatmış? -5'te. Nerede
bitirmiş? + 2'de bitirmiş. Buna göre bu
fonksiyonun tanım ve görüntü kümelerini
bulunuz. Şimdi benim sana burada ekstra
açıklayacağım noktalar var. Lütfen
benimle birlikte bu grafiği çizer misin
güzel arkadaşım? Hemen doğrusal referans
fonksiyonunun grafiğini çizeceğim. Öyle
ekstra özel bir şey çizmeyeceğim
aslında. Hemen doğrusal referans
fonksiyonunun grafiğini çizelim buraya.
Şurası biliyorsun ki y ekseni.
Biliyorsun ki burası x ekseni. Doğrusal
referans fonksiyonu tam ortadan ikiye
bölüyor aslında şurayı. Hatta açısal
olarak söyleyebilirim ki 45'e 45 ayırır.
Matematiksel olarak da bu yorumu
yapabiliriz. Bu arkadaş kimdi? f(x) = x
doğrusal referans fonksiyonuydu. Hocam
bu doğrusal referans fonksiyonunda şuna
karşılık gelen noktalar bak şurada
x'lerin karşılık gelen noktaları
yeşillerin tamamına bakma. X eksenine
değdiği noktalara bak. X ekseninde
taradığı bölge diyelim ki son nokta
burası olsun. Şurası A nok. Hop! A'yı
yazamadık. Şurası A noktası olsun.
Şurası da B noktası olsun. X ekseninde
grafiğin taradığı bölgeyi söyle bana.
Bak gerçekten bu grafik en sonda B'yi
tarayabiliyor. Aradaki bütün değerleri
tanıyor. İşte X ekseni benim için neydi?
Tanım kümesiydi. Ama X ekseninin tamamı
değil. Grafiğimde taradığım bölge. Bana
eğer bu soruda ben genel olarak
söylüyorum tabii. Tanım kümesini bulun
derse ne yapacağım hocam? B'de
başlamışım, A'da bitirmişim. Demek ki
kapalı mı? Kapalı. B kapalı. A kapalı
aralığı bizim tanım kümemizdir. Bunu
anladık mı? Şimdi geldim. Her zaman
tanım kümesi sorulmuyor. Görüntü kümesi
kimdi? Y'ydi. Y'de taranan Y'yde ne ya?
G Y ekseninde taranan bölgeye bakıyorum.
Y ekseninde taranan bölgeye bakalım mı?
Tam bu nokta en dip bölgem. En dipten
bak grafikte tarayarak ilerliyorum.
Grafikte y eksenine karşılık gelen
noktaları göstererek gidiyorum. Y
eksenine karşılık gelen noktaları
göstererek gidiyorum. Gidiyorum,
gidiyorum. En son nokta burası mı? Ben
de diyorum ki bak şu noktaya karşılık
gelen yer D olsun. Şu noktaya karşılık
gelen yer C olsun. Y ekseninde en dipte
C'nin hizasında başlıyorum. Nerede
bitiriyorum? D''nin hizasında
bitiriyorum. Hiç boşluk da atmıyorum. O
halde benim bu fonksiyonumun görüntü
kümesini gel beraber yazalım. Görüntü
kümesi nedir hocam? Görüntü kümesi C'de
başladı, D'de bitti. Bunu anladın mı?
Bunu anladıysan bu olay bitmiştir
abiciğim. Bu olay bitmiştir. Aşağıdaki
grafik g = f(x) doğrusal referans
fonksiyonuna aittir. Verilen grafiğe
göre f(x) fonksiyonunun tanım ve görüntü
kümelerini yazınız. Şimdi az önce
anlattığım mevzuyu gel beraber çözmeye
çalışalım. Grafik üzerinde bir şey
diyeceğim ya. Anlıyorsun değil mi?
İlgiyle de takip ediyorsun. Hadi
inşallah bakalım. Gel. X ekseninde en
sonda geldiğim yer neresi? -5. Bak,
-5'ten itibaren hiç boşluk bırakıyor mu
grafik bana? X'in karşısında x'ten dik
doğrular çiz ya da x'ten doğrular çiz
grafiğe. Çizdim, çizdim, çizdim. Boşluk
yok. Devam ettim. 0ın hizasından da
geçtim. Çizdim, çizdim, çizdim, çizdim.
X'in hizasını da kimde bitirdim? + 2'de
bitirdim. X ekseninde taranan bölge
bizim için tanım kümesiydi. O halde bu
soruda tanım kümesi dediğimde başladığım
nokta -5'i açık aralık + 2 pardon kapalı
aralık -5 kapalı ve 2 kapalı aralık.
Nereden anlıyorduk kapalı aralık
olduğunu? Ucu kapalı noktaydı. Şimdi
geldim görüntü kümesine. Bence olayı
benden önce çözeceksin. Burada -5'in
hizasına geldim yine. A denk gelmiş
hocam. -5'in hizasından başladım.
Başladım. Başladım. Başladım. Başladım.
Geldim. denk gelmemiş aslında. -5'e
karşılık gelen nokta -5'tir. Referans
fonksiyonunda y ekseninde taradığım
bölge nerede bitti hocam? + 2'de bitti.
O halde artık biz buraya ne diyeceğiz? Y
ekseninde taranan bölge bizim için
görüntü kümesidir. Görüntü kümesinin de
taradığı sınırlar neresidir? -5'e + 2
kapalı aralıdır. Mük oldu mu abiciğim?
Vallahi mük oldu. Gerçekten mük oldu
diyorum buraya. Bence anlaşıldı. Burası
taranan bölgelere bakıyoruz hocam. Olay
bu. Peki soruyu zorlaştırayım ben sana.
Aşağıda verilen analitik düzlemde -3 4
tanım kümesine sahip f(x) = x referans
fonksiyonunun grafiğini çiziniz. Şimdi
herhangi bir sınırlama yapmazsa yani
soru şöyle gelseydi eğer gerçek
sayılarda tanımlı. Gerçek sayılarda
tanımlı. Bak,
f(x) = x referans fonksiyonunun
grafiğini çizin deseydi nasıl
çiziyordun? Tam böyle 2'ye bölecek
şekilde çiziyorduk. Bak + 1'e 1den +
2'ye 2'den geçecek şekilde çiziyorduk.
Ama bu soru özellikle -3'ün hizasından
başla diyor. Tanım kümesi x'ler demekti.
-1, -2, -3. Kapalı aralık mı hocam?
Kapalı aralık. -3'ün hizasından başla
diyor. Grafiği çizmeye nerede bitir
diyor? +4'te. +1 + 2 + 3 + 4 + 4'ün
hizası da burası mı grafikte? Burası.
Şimdi grafik üzerinde sadece bu bölgeyi
çizeceksin. Çizdim ama kırmızıyla mavi
karışmasın diye kırmızıyı siliyorum.
Müthiş oldu. Al sana verilen tanım
aralığında çizilmesi gereken doğrusal
referans fonksiyonumuz bu. He ne anladık
abim? Doğrusal referans fonksiyonunun
grafiği verilen tanımın kümesine göre
değişir. Çizerken bütün gerçek sayılarda
dersem çaprazlama bütün her yeri
çizerim. Belli bir aralık sorarsa tıpkı
bu sorudaki gibi bu aralığı göstererek
çizmek zorundayım. Ve aralığımı da
gösterdim. Bu aralıkta çizdim grafiğimi.
Peki sormuyor soruda ama bana sen söyler
misin? Görüntü kümesi neresidir hocam?
Görüntü kümesi Y ekseninde taradığımız
bölgeydi. Y ekseninde en dipte nereye
geldim? -3. En tepede nereye geldim? +4.
O halde görüntü kümesinin aralığını yaz
deseydi sorumuz bize ne diyecektik? -3'e
+4 kap aralığı da bunun görüntü
kümesidir diyecektik. Hatta hatta
fonksiyonlar şöyle gösterilir.
Fonksiyonu a'dan b'ye doğru tanımlanır.
Burada ekstra bilgimiz olsun. A'dan B'ye
doğru tanımlanan bu kümede burası tanım
kümesi. Burası nedir? Görüntü kümesidir.
Ben bunu tıpkı burada yazdığım gibi
fonksiyonumu yazmak isteseydim şöyle
yazacaktım. F fonksiyonu -3'e 4 kapalı
aralığından hangi aralığa doğru
çizilmiş? -3 4 kapalı aralığına doğru.
Hani kalkar başka bir soruda. Bunu
sağlayan doğru sağlı fonksiyonunun
grafiğini çizin dediğinde şuna bak.
Tanım kümesi burası. Sonra grafiği çiz.
Bitti. Geldim. Peki hocam yeni marif
model bizden böyle sorular istemiyor.
Onlar klasik. Tamam gelebilir öyle soru
da onlar klasik sorular. Yeni nesil
dediğimiz sorularda bizden ne istiyor?
Tarih ve matematik işbirliğinde bir
proje ödevi hazırlayan Seda doğrusal
referans fonksiyonunu kullanarak f(x) =
x'i kullanacak. Tarihsel olayları
modellemek istiyor. Bunun için x = 0
olarak kabul edilmektedir milat. Tamam
biz de öyle kabul ediyoruz. Genelde
ödevini hazırlarken yazının icadı olan
milattan önce 3200 yılını başlangıç alıp
İstanbul'un fethini yani milattan sonra
1453'ü de bitiş olarak kabul ediyor.
Şimdi mesela burası bir eee tarih
çizgisi olsaydı. Bak tarih çizgisi
olsaydı tarih çizgisinde başlangıcı
neresi kabul ettim diyor? Milattan önce.
Milattan önce 3200 kabul ettim diyor.
Arada diyor 0 milat var. Bir de milattan
sonra 1453'ü de bitiş kabul ettim diyor.
Bu aralıkta ben fonksiyonumu çizeceğim.
Demek ki bu fonksiyonun öncelikle tanım
kümesi neresi olur? Tanım kümesi bizim
x'lerimiz bu aralıktır. Tabii ben bunu
yazarken milattan önceyi -3.200
alacağım. Milattan sonrayı + 1453. Reel
sayılarda göstermek zorundayım ya gerçek
sayılarda. O yüzden -3200'den
+ 1453'e
kadar bu kapalı aralığı çizeceğim. Soru
benden görüntü kümesini de istiyor ama
gel ben bu görüntü kümesini önce burada
düzlemde zaten soruda ekstra bizden şeyi
de istiyor. Grafiğini de istiyor ya.
Grafikte gösterelim biz bunu. Grafiğe
göre yorumlarız zaten. Doğrusal referans
fonksiyonu normalde böyle çiziyordum
değil mi? Tam böyle açıortay yapacak
şekilde aramızda kalsın. Hava atarsın
arkadaş ortamında. Buna birinci açıortay
doğrusu da denir. Ha ben ilk öğretmen
olduğumda beni öğretmenlik sınavına
aldılar. Bunu sordular. Bu doğrunun adı
nedir? Doğrusal pardon birinci açıortay
doğrusu da denir. Ekstra ekstra
bilgiler. Matematik öğrenmek istiyorum
diyenlerin bilgisi. Ama diyor bu grafiği
diyor sınırlarda çiz diyor. Nerede
başlayacak bu sınır? Ekside 3200'de
artıda nerede bitecek bu sınır hocam?
1453'te
bitecek. Peki bu doğrusal referans
fonksiyonu Allah yanlışlıkla sildim.
doğrusal referans fonksiyonu olduğuna
göre buna karşılık gelen y değeri ne
olur? X yerine X yerine 1453 yazarsan
herkesi kendine götürüyordu. Y değeri de
kaç olacak? 1453.
Aynı şekilde -3200
yazarsan y değeri de ne olacak? -3200
olacak. -3200'de de bu grafik bitiyor. O
halde geri döndüm. Tanım kümesini zaten
yazmıştım. Görüntü kümesi. Görüntü
kümesi eşittir hocam. -3200'de
başladık. 1453'te
kapattık. Tanım kümesi, görüntü kümesi
çizildi. Grafik çizildi. O da bitti.
Fonksiyonun 0ı. Fonksiyonun 0ı y'sinin 0
olduğu yerdir. Adı üstünde bu fonksiyon
nasıl bir fonksiyondu? Doğrusal referans
fonksiyonu. Doğrusal referans fonksiyonu
ne zaman 0 olur? x = 0 olduğunda
fonksiyonun 0ı x = 0'dır. Peki hocam
bana bu nokta olarak yazar mısın desem
mesela a koordinat olarak yazsam 0a 0
noktası bu fonksiyonun 0ı aldığı değerin
olduğu yerdir. Ama fonksiyonun 0'ını bul
dediğinde x e= bana bir sayı söylemen
lazım. x = 0 bu fonksiyonun 0'ıdır.
Anlaştık mı? Güzel. İşaret tablosunu
çizin. İşaret tablosu aslında neydi?
Sayı doğrusu demekti hocam. Bak buraya
x'lerin değerini yazacağım. eksi sonsuz
artı sonsuz. Aşağıya da fx'lerin
işaretini yazarız. Karışmasın diye
aslında buraya tabloya. O tablo
dediğimiz şey sayı doğrusundan oluşuyor.
Kim ne derse desin. Belki bunu da ilk
defa duyuyorlardır. Buradan çizgi
çekilir karışmasın diye. Önce
fonksiyonun 0'ı gösterilir. Nerede 0
oluyor? X = 0'da. Fonksiyonun değeri de
burada 0 çıktığı için biz onun hizasına
buraya da 0 yazarız. O 0ın anlamı o.
Hani oram buraya galiba sembol
koyuyorsunuz. Evet. Buraya 0 koymamızın
sebebi bu fonksiyonun değeri 0 çıktığı
için koyuluyor. Bak fonksiyon diyor
burada 0 oldu diyor. Peki bu fonksiyon
gerçekten şu bölgede f(x)'lerin değeri
hep nasıl değerler aldı? Pozitif. Şu
bölgede f(x)'ler nasıl değerler aldı?
Negatif. 0'ın büyük değerlerinde bu
fonksiyon pozitif değerler aldı. 0'dan
küçük değerlerde negatif değerler aldı.
Al sana. Bu da işaret tablosu. Ey güzel
arkadaşım aslında normalde artanlık,
azalananlık, maksimum, minimumlukla
devam edip ardından da beraber efsane
sorular çözeceğiz. Ama onu bir sonraki
derse saklıyorum. Buraya kadar
fonksiyonlara efsane bir giriş
yaptığımızı düşünüyorum. Fonksiyonlarda
hiçbir şeyi kaçırmak istemiyorsan, her
şeyi tas tamam ve mantığıyla öğrenmek
istiyorsan biz yolumuza devam edeceğiz.
Modül 2'deyiz. Modül 2'den yolumuza bir
sonraki derslere devam. Bu dersi de
kesinlikle kaçırma ki lise hayatının en
önemli matematik dersi olan nicelikler
ve değişimler konusunda çok iyi kendine
çok iyi bak. Videoyu beğendiysen beğen
tuşuna basmayı aynı zamanda bunu
söylüyorum ama yorum atarsanız gerçekten
çok mutlu olurum 9. sınıf tayfam
gücünüzü bir gösterin bakalım bu
videoda. Kendinize iyi bakın. Hoşça
kalın. Hoşça kalın. Gerçekten
seviliyorsunuz. [müzik]
H
[müzik]